The Joe Rogan Experience what do you
think about Elon Musk saying that
overpopulation is a myth and it's
actually the opposite what do you think
about that well it is the opposite in
places where the developed World exists
like in in big cities people are having
less children yeah I know a lot of a lot
of guys in their 40s they're not even
close to being married no kids they're
not gonna have kids that's happening
everywhere so it's lifestyle choices for
sure that happen when people live in big
cities and they concentrate on their
career this also happens when uh in
these uh most people are in the big
cities though right and where women
aren't oppressed where women aren't
oppressed and they can pursue careers
they pursue careers as they put off
childbirth it's like this that's the the
theme of Idiocracy remember the member
idiocracy I didn't see it I hear about
it all the time until recently it's
[ __ ] I gotta go area it's my judge
right yes I love myself really [ __ ]
the new Beavis and Butthead movie better
than ever I haven't seen it yet it's
like two months old so good I had Mike
Judge in here a couple of months ago
Dude they go to space dude
it's so good it's so good so the premise
of Idiocracy is there's this really
smart couple and they keep putting it
off keep putting off having kids and at
the same time you're showing this dude
lives in trailer park he's [ __ ] all
these chicks near him he knocks up her
and she's chasing him with a frying pan
cause she found out he knocked up her
too and it's wild yeah and it's just
like it just shows how people are just
getting dumber and dumber the Dumber
people are overpopulating the smart
people aren't having anything like you
bet yeah like the bit from 2005. so
that's really what it is I mean this is
exactly what Elon is saying yeah is that
in these cities there is a depopulation
problem then there's also another
problem Dr Shanna Swann we had her on
the podcast she wrote a book called
countdown and it's all about phthalates
and how phthalates are getting into
people's blood supplies from Plastics
and how it's directly affecting our
reproductive systems it's making men's
dicks smaller oh no smaller and taints
smaller and the way they ident identify
mammals males or females is the male's
taint is 50 to 100 larger and the
introduction of phthalates they know
these from studies when you introduce
phthalates into the blood supply of
these these creatures like mice and
rodents and [ __ ] like that they're all
of their taints shrink and that's
exactly what's happening to people and
we have phthalates in our blood so they
do these these blood tests on people and
they find all these microplastics and
all this residue from petrochemical
products and if you look at when
petrochemical products are introduced
and Plastics are introduced in America
and then look at sperm counts look at
miscarriage rates look at dick sizes all
that stuff testicle sizes all shrink
skip that part
if a girl if a girl licks your taint
does she get credit for eating man ass
it's pretty close she's in the
neighborhood you know it's like your
Beverly Hills adjacent
does she get credit I think he does damn
that's a risky
remember I don't know if you remember I
brought this up on the podcast before
and I don't know if it's true I hear it
no uh you got we didn't have a debunking
website or whatever but
um the saying that the entire population
of the world whatever it is 7 billion or
something can all fit in Texas or Alaska
in their own house remember that I think
if you stuffed everybody together like a
favela totally no no totally right yeah
it would have to be that yeah right and
then the rest of it's Farmland but even
Heathen Ethan if it wasn't Texas it has
to be the whole United States like you
could fit the whole population of the
world of the world in the United States
they're saying you could fit them in
Texas or Alaska that's what they're
saying yeah nobody's debunked that and I
don't know no but he probably could fit
him physically the problem is where are
you gonna get on that thing I'm not
saying I'm not saying hey let's let's
all move them to Alaska this is just oh
here it is standing shoulder to shoulder
the entire world's population can fit
within 500 square miles of Los Angeles
Los Angeles what
so if that's true so it must be true
right if that's true even if let's just
say that's off and it's the whole United
States I know it's only L.A right if
that's true okay
there ain't nobody on this [ __ ]
dude that would mean if we got everybody
in Alaska or everybody in Texas and the
whole world was empty right all of South
America
Asia Russia to me
that means this overpopulation [ __ ]
is a [ __ ] myth man but wait a minute
that doesn't make any sense because what
they're saying in this Los Angeles thing
is people stand shoulder to shoulder
yeah I'm just saying if that's true if
that's no I'm not saying to live that
way I'm just saying if you can do that
if you could fit the whole population
that's plenty of room for everybody dude
right back in the when I first started
flying and uh teaching seminars all over
the world I would always just look out
the plane and go all I see is just
nobody I see a city way over there City
way over there and go it's empty I go we
should all have a plot of land
that's what I'd be thinking I go there's
so much Wasteland when you fly across
the United States dude there's only
people in La New York Miami and San
Francisco everything else is empty dude
you're on a plane there's nobody there's
nobody here so I don't want so when
people talk about climate change well
we're we're causing climate change or
overpopulation and then you got Elon
Musk saying that's the one thing I'm
like damn Elon Musk is saying that
saying that overpopulation is a myth
it's actually the reverse like whoa so I
don't want to hear anything about an
over [ __ ] population oh it seems
overpopulated when you're in a city and
you're living in a father and they got
you all crammed into a city super smart
cities and all that [ __ ] yeah it's
overpopulated but the rest of the
world's empty it's [ __ ] empty
well there's a lot of people that you
have to feed that's the problem the
problem is not just the number of people
the problem is the resource do you
believe cow farts are melting icebergs
cow farts are not the problem it's
actually burps it's methods it's methane
but it's just but there's also ways they
use regenerative farming so it's carbon
neutral you know there's people that
have like discussed regenerative farming
the only problem is like scaling it for
millions and millions of people but it's
just a natural product of animals eating
grass they do know that that happens
dude you know how bad those farts gotta
stink give them to melt icebergs it's
melting Iceberg it's just releasing
that's what climate change it's all
about melting icebergs rising sea levels
it's all about the iceberg but it
definitely polar bears it definitely
contributes to the gases do you know
that have you ever gone to like one of
those places that just grow cows my
parents used to live in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania I used to have to drive
through Farmland bro it smells so oh bad
it smells so bad like the people that
I've driven through Farmland before you
could smell the cow [ __ ] no no it's not
just cow [ __ ] where they raise cattle
not not I mean like millions and
millions of cats I will never believe
cow farts are
causing climate there's no way anybody's
gonna believe that or their burps the
burps it's contributing to the gases
that are in the environment you know
what Dan Pena is saying and with with
the Steve coonan is saying more
specifically is that we're talking about
a negligible effect in comparison to all
these other effects I wonder how I want
to see a documentary on how they've they
found out cow farts are are burning a
hole in the Ozarks it's really burp
burps it's just it's just methane man
but I'm telling you these uh carbon
neutral Farmers these people that use
regenerative farming they take the
manure and they put it back into the
soil and that's that's what they use for
fertilizer and everything is organic and
they're saying if you do it that's the
way animals and the environment are
supposed to interact what we've done
that's so [ __ ] is factory farming and
we've taken all these animals and shoved
them into these places and made these
toxic lace waste Lakes of animal waste
have you seen those with the fly a drone
over these um factory farming setups
they have for pigs like dude if
everybody wants sausage and everybody
wants bacon you need a lot of [ __ ]
pigs a lot of pigs and it's horrific
what they have to do to raise pigs in an
economical way so you can get cheap
bacon is pretty [ __ ] that's real
because that is 100 contributing to the
amount of methane that gets released in
gases that get really because if you go
anywhere near those places they're
[ __ ] terrible toxic they smell awful
man like that shit's if you live in that
City and they open up like a some sort
of a factory farming setup right outside
of town guess what your city's ruined
you're gonna smell that [ __ ] you're
gonna and you're gonna get used to the
smell unfortunately because all Factory
senses the olfactory senses detect
changes in smells that's why people
stink they don't smell themselves
because otherwise be like oh my God I
smell gotta get the [ __ ] out of here you
detect changes in smell so if you live
in a place that stinks like some parts
of New Jersey when they were like really
polluted they have factories out there
the people that lived there didn't even
know it stunk people had to come visit
them and go what the [ __ ] are you living
where are you living man you know bad it
smells here that makes it smells normal
because they're used to it they get
accustomed to it that 100 is
contributing to pollution so whether
it's factory farming or whether it's
factories all the different things that
people do that we and Joy if you want
electricity something's got to burn like
how do you do it do you use coal what do
you do unless you're going to do nuclear
it's gonna you're gonna have some
[ __ ] you're going to have some
negative effect